so surprise for when you heard your name
at three but what's the emotion you felt
when you didn't hear your name at one
surprise but at the same time i was just
like okay that team didn't want me move
on and the next team didn't want me but
when the team finally called my name it
was like i got to go into this situation
and just give it my all because it took
a chance on me when other teams didn't
was that moment as crazy for you as it
was for all of us working or watching
because it was like all of a sudden
everything changed was it that kind of
it was definitely crazy like i was over
here shaking like that was the first
time i ever like felt like you know when
people say i was shaking like i was
really shaking i couldn't like stop you
know what i mean just because i didn't
know where i was gonna go because i
thought i was gonna go one or two i
didn't go one or two so who knows what
if i don't go three you know i mean like
it was just so many emotions and so many
possibilities in my head you know my
name was called it was like like i said
everything just left my body and it was
like all positive